I'm Michael hi I'm your our regular
laughing about it's like I didn't expect
you to call me yeah okay you're the
you're the brains of this organization
please please don't say that I'm the the
wild card Jake's the muscle
[Music]
Michael hi um you are a regular PC
hardware and games expert here in
GameSpot I want to throw you a softball
right away I PC gaming in 2018 what are
the broad strokes how'd it go
improvements let's see I'll start with
the hardware stuff get the boring stuff
by the way now I'm just kidding it's
kind of exciting this year at least well
depends on how you look at it because
Nvidia dropped their new video cards
late this year and their big thing was
like you know we're bringing ray-tracing
to video games and it's kind of like
alright that's cool like especially with
all their demos and it's more or less a
proof of concept you know it's gonna
take a while for games to adapt to new
graphics technologies so they're out
there on stage like showing like you
know this is how Metro Exodus is gonna
look this is how battlefield 5 is gonna
look with ray-tracing and it's like
alright that's that's cool but when I
played battlefield 5 like I'm not gonna
be paying attention to reflections and
all the other stuff but the video cars
themselves are an improvement over past
generation but they are pretty expensive
so it's that also plays into
cryptocurrency
I don't need to go through that whole
thing again but it's worth mentioning
because for a very long time it was
impossible to get video cards for MSRP
regular price and so everyone who was
into PC gaming like threw a fit and I
mean it was kind of I understand why
because you know to get a $400 card for
$1,000 is ridiculous because people were
mining cryptocurrency but now that's
kind of died down but I think like with
the new video cards coming in I almost
feel like the the regular price for
these cards have gotten higher but you
usually see usually see that throughout
history but at this rate I feel like you
know PC hardware is still getting really
expensive so I kind of understand the
sentiment like when things are too
expensive to upgrade or buy new hardware
that's just how I feel then
cryptocurrency affect the pricing of
that stuff as much as it did last year
last year was like when that really 2018
was peak yeah it really it really hit
this year so
yeah it was really tough to get video
cards and so it's kind of like I checked
out of PC gaming hardware for a while I
was like I'll come back when it dies
down and it died down as soon as videos
started like rolling out a new video
cards so you know stuff so expensive
though all right all right you two I
know you played like pretty much most PC
exclusives this year between the four of
us I think we all did and we can get
into other games that play best on PC
but Jake what is your like what was a
standout PC game this year that you
might not have been able to play or you
wouldn't been able to play on consoles
at this point I think the forest get
guys I got this guys take a break I got
this guy I mean I guess that came out a
while ago it was an early access they
updated it regularly until finally it
came out this year I think I wanna say
early was early this year but I didn't
play any of the early acts of stuff I
just jumped in when it came out did some
co-op and it ended up being probably the
most engaging game I've played all year
that's like all the office was talking
about for like two weeks yeah it was
you'd all play together and you uncover
this story together while doing all
these survival elements which I know
people are kind of tired of those
especially the fallout 76 people are
like alright I don't want survival in my
games but I think the way they did it
was really clever how they kind of
pieced the story out as you go you can
kind of discover it in any way you want
to and it's not super exposition heavy
so you don't really need to be paying
attention you just walk through a cave
find a new item that you're stoked
because that means you can get to a new
area within the caves and then you find
a small piece of storytelling and this
builds to a very exciting ending I would
say where you explore this locked vault
I don't want to spoil it just case
anyone's interested in in it but I
remember coming in the office and just
being so excited to get home see what's
behind that vault see what's next plan
out what we're gonna do where we're
gonna build our next fort it was it was
a blast like I that is definitely the
highlight
of 2018 for me so far that's one your
favorite games of the year right I think
so it's up there's probably two or three
as of this recording as of the previous
weekend that's on ps4 as well it is on
ps4 now so a PC the vast majority of
yeah I definitely give it a shot on ps4
if you don't have a PC but it seems like
I have a feeling pcs probably the best
way to play it just mouse and keyboard
it probably runs a lot smoother because
even that game kind of didn't run the
best as I was playing it but I haven't
played ps4 so I can't really speak to
that but it's definitely worth the try
oh my god I am hauling oh I just oh oh
boy oh my god Johnny who's flying so
fast do you have a PC exclusive so to
speak that you really stood out this
year aside from the forest yeah so for
me like PC was kind of where I could
find some of those more niche titles
that kind of like fill that that
specific void that people are looking
for pillars of eternity to keep in the C
RPG genre alive although I guess it's
the last independent game from obsidian
home that they've been acquired by
Microsoft I'm hoping that Microsoft
still lets them like put out these kinds
of games of like just focused on PC yeah
because it is it's really really good
like it so this is sequel to pillars of
eternity one and it continues that story
in a in a way that reminds me of like
Baldur's Gate 2 well this gate 1 to 2
but they just add so much like it takes
place in the like southern half of the
continent in the world so it's not like
pirate-themed you get a boat they added
this whole like boat minigame where
you're like fighting other ships but
it's all just like text menus and sound
effects
it's a great example of a game that uses
does a lot with like a small budget like
I mean it uses these like pre-rendered
backgrounds like old-school C RPGs did
but because of like modern tech they are
like some of the most beautiful like
pre-rendered backgrounds you've ever
seen and it gives the game like a really
gorgeous art style that you could tell
they were able to do like really cheaply
mm-hmm
because it was kick-started I believe
yeah as well and yeah I mean it still
got that great writing I think I was a
little concerned because Chris Avalon
left and like he was heavily involved in
the first one I think there are X
aspects of the first one I like better
but like the writing is still really
sharp like obsidian still got like I
think they are at this point probably my
favorite Western RPG developer my
personal favorite PC game this year was
throne breaker so what's your tales your
grace get more coal
they fill their bellies mal this doesn't
bode well
oh no no burn at all it's easy to just
say it's went in with a story mode but
like I started playing it a few weeks
ago like Jake I know you've been
covering a lot and you played a lot of
Gwen coming out from CD Projekt as like
a spinoff I think it just the perfect
spin-off I've talked about it a lot how
it gives you a different perspective on
like the northern kingdoms in Geralt
like you see Gerald and that's no secret
now he's in a lot of key art but you're
playing queen meave and she is the fact
that she is a ruler and you had these
difficult decisions to make and it kind
of makes sense you're building up your
deck or your army as you're trying to
like again I'm not gonna spoil anything
but the way that that game weaves it's
like deck-building card game which I
don't traditionally care for I played a
little bit of hearthstone and that was
about it the way it weaves that into a
legitimately fantastic RPG story set in
the witcher universe was like like
absolutely nuts and i loved it and i
know that's also coming to consoles
soonish but obviously like throughout
the year the main way to play that was
on pc the voice acting and writing voice
i think in particular is just top-notch
yeah yeah queen eve that whoever I wish
I knew who voiced her but it's it's so
good yeah my threats are never Hollow
and if it's an escape you way well we've
yet to see any man abscond from the
dungeons of
castle also the card battles are not
just hey it's just go went with AI my
parents like they probably the best part
about that game is like the puzzle
battles where you're given a very
specific set of cards and like a certain
conditions you have to meet in like one
turn to accomplish it yeah and you know
they only serve amount of turns and and
those like you'll just kind of like keep
like banging your head like again and
again but you're like no I I'm so close
like I know exactly I did yeah they have
like one health point left and you lose
like there's just like one miss like I
just need to order this yeah and that's
like really satisfying in it like even
if you're like I don't really like card
games like that at that point it's not a
card game it's a puzzle game using these
cards like that in itself it's just like
really and if you don't like card games
you can skip all of those and just do
the story that's true then itself I
think is really good like after you get
past that first chapter and like the I
don't know the the inciting incident I
guess you'd say happens it like really
picks up and it goes some pretty neat
places I'd say and even in a year when
Red Dead Redemption 2 came out I think
throne breaker is my favorite soundtrack
that soundtrack is utterly amazing it's
still got the lutes and everything you
expect from The Witcher universe but
it's just like super anthemic like amped
up kind of music when you're battling
but then also needs quiet ambient songs
when you're not
and he got the console is secure your
grace all right well I feel like I have
to at least mention over din which I've
been playing a ton of
[Music]
it's by a Lucas Pope the guy who made
papers please for those who are familiar
with that game and it's like an
old-school first-person like murder
mystery game I grew up playing games
like mist and like 60 times murder
mystery times six yeah murder three
times sixty it's like you're an
insurance agent who's on this ship and
you're trying to figure out like what
happened to the crew and you have this
compass device that lets you see the
moment in which a person died you so
you'll just get like the audio right
before and then you see their death you
have this logbook where you're basically
like okay this person I gotta figure out
who they are like how they died and who
killed them and you're you're basically
like taking like mental notes and you're
kind of like hopping back in time
through like the different sections of
like the ship's voyage and you're like
okay well I know this guy shot him but I
don't know who that guy's name is and
then you know you'll find like a event
that happened like 60 days before we're
like he was in a argument with this
other guy and that guy mentions his name
so okay now I know who that guy is it's
it sounds really complicated but I think
the best thing about it is that the game
is designed in a way it designs the
journal in a very elegant clean way
where it's actually not that hard to
like keep track of all the pieces and
that's that's that's to means like the
glue that holds it all together I feel
like this game could have been really
easy to just fall apart where you're
like I have no idea what I'm doing or
it's way too hard I'm I can't keep track
of all this but I think the game is
designed in such a way that it just you
feel really really smart
whenever you figure like I know who that
guy is
yeah I mean like it's it's as good as it
can be right before it gets overwhelming
he walked the line like perfectly but
before it got like too much totally and
it is one of the better games of the
year and you can only play on PC yeah
and that art style oh yeah and you can
change it between like the Commodore 64
and like in the menu and like between
all the other yeah like different like
IBM computers and like it defaults like
a Macintosh and yeah that's so cool
yeah you can make it like the orange of
the Commodore 64
I feel like most years some of the best
games can be played on PC I like just to
think back like a few years ago there's
Witcher 3 overwatch I think you like you
have the option to play those games on
PC this year as of now with no read
direction 2 on PC yet people are still
waiting for a rockstar to say what their
plans are that because the original Red
Dead did not come to PC still has not do
you think like I think PC players in
terms of exclusives were missing out on
some of the they are on the best games
of the year yeah I definitely think so I
think my my sentiment with PC gaming was
like oh this is the best platform to
play multi-platform games and that still
holds true like for me playing a lot of
FPS like I always go to PC like keyboard
mouse controls and also being able to do
like 60fps has been always my thing so I
do think about the exclusive that
exclusives that they are missing out on
and it's I think now more than ever it's
like yeah they are missing on some very
big games I mean there is God of War
franchise has been around for a long
time but like there's something
particularly special about that game and
then Red Dead Redemption to you and then
spider-man spider-man it's like aha Dan
like I spent more time like I usually
play PC whenever I can but this year and
last year I played my ps4 more than PC
so but going back to your point about
how PC is very much for these niche
games and I still think there's like
value in that this is like the platform
where people can experiment and do
smaller size projects that try very
different things there's a lot of still
a lot of innovation in PC games but it's
not gonna come from you know the big
Triple A games and use these new video
cards that just came out like
battlefield 5 is a multi-platform game
look plays and looks best on PC I'm
gonna play that game on PC all the time
but I mean where the innovation happens
with games like over Dan with games like
throne breaker is gonna come to consoles
but that originated on PC there's still
a lot of dope stuff out there so yeah
yeah that's an exclusive right there and
that's not a game that's gonna like push
video cards or anything so there's still
innovation happening on PC and they're
also going back to when I was talking
about video cards like I used to be all
about like when like when the r-tx
arts came out I was like this is cool
but I don't really I'm not really
feeling that enthusiasm anymore
I guess because like all the games that
I do want to play on PC don't require
that like I still have a gtx 970 and one
of my computers and i'm still play
everything i want to on pc so that's two
generations behind the r-tx cards that
just came out this year so I don't
really feel the urge to jump on to that
new ship now also like it's kind of
fascinating I feel like this year is
when Microsoft and Sony's efforts to
adapt that PC hardware improvement cycle
with their consoles I feel like this
year maybe it's just because Red Dead
Redemption 2 looked so good on Xbox 1x
specifically yeah and not just the Pro
like even more so on the X I feel like
those efforts to move more toward that
life cycle of like PC parts and not just
the old like seven years one console and
they ever got the ps4 I feel like that's
actually that came to fruition pretty
well this year and I wonder if I know
the gap isn't closed at all between
consoles and PC but I wonder if like
there is the sense that it closed the
gap a lot yeah and also when you think
about like Xbox is kind of making a big
deal about keyboard and mouse support so
I mean it's not like we haven't seen it
in action really all that much yet but
you know it's pricketts progress so at
some point like maybe it's gonna be like
well okay we're gonna have for example
whatever obsidian comes out with it's
gonna come out PC and Xbox is like well
i haveno 1x and i have keyboard and
mouse support then you know it kind of
stepping on toes of the PC if you look
at it that way but I mean Microsoft runs
Windows so it's like I suppose it
doesn't matter all that much what
platform you play on I think that
there's a lot of conversations going on
we're like hey games are gonna be moving
to streaming services rather than you
know hard disk copies and we're already
doing digital downloads most of our
games so what's the next step is flying
me streaming we saw that with like
Nvidia has always done GeForce now it's
still in beta but Google did the project
stream for AC Odyssey and when I tested
that out I was kinda like alright this
this kind of works this is it's it's not
the best quality but you know it's
running fine for that type of game so
but I think about a lot of the PC games
that have stood the test of time or like
multiplayer games like I play still play
a lot of counter-strike
I will never play that through a
streaming service because of how precise
and how fast that game happens and so I
mean I don't know maybe we'll get to a
point where that's it's negligible but
at least Google project stream was a
proof-of-concept that you know this can
work fairly easily too cuz that it ran
perfectly fine in my eyes yeah no matter
what at the end of the day my PC is
still the best place to play Rainbow six
siege I feel the best game around yeah a
man I could argue with like even there's
all these great exclusives like the game
I still come back to on PC is rain to
succeed yeah that's like probably my
most played PC game last year this year
yeah that's what most people play
continuing games like fortnight on PC
yeah I can do it with like Lucy and Joey
and stuff and it's it's just so easy to
jump back on my PC and everything it's
just already updated and I don't have to
like I don't have to worry about the
Xbox one download speeds yeah I'm like
I'm gonna bring it into the office for
the higher speed I actually want to get
back to playing siege but if you're
watching we have a full report card on
gamespot comm from the editorial team
going more into specifics about PC in
2018 so go check that out and we will be
covering other platforms throughout the
coming weeks so you know
[Music]